hello welcome to science breakthroughs
from science mission I'm so that your
pie I'm going to discuss couple of
breakthrough papers published in the
week of june twenty third let's start
first we will discuss a paper published
by Vivek mahadevan in cell reports on
the regulation of chloride homeostasis
in neurons why is this paper so
important increased intracellular
neuronal chloride is linked to numerous
neurological disorders including
epilepsy autism and neuropathic pain low
intracellular chloride is maintained by
kcc2 a neuron-specific potassium
chloride cotransporter others elicited
healer to unknown mechanism of
regulation of kcc2 using whole brain
membrane fraction immunoprecipitation
experiments authors demonstrate
interaction between kcc2 and glutamate
kainate receptor subunits the
interaction is further confirmed by
co-immunoprecipitation experiments in
hek293 cells and HIPAA camel neuronal
immunostaining authors further
demonstrate using antibody shift assay
and 2d gel electrophoresis that native
kcc2 and glutamate Kainat subunits exist
in the same oligomeric complex others
also show less oligomerization and
decreased kcc2 in expression at the
surface in glutamate kinase subunit
knockout hippocampal neurons cultures
indicating the importance of glutamate
Kainat subunits in kcc2 oligomerization
and expression when kcc2 activity was
measured by recording the reversal
potential for gaba others formed that ii
gaba was depolarized in glutamate chi
net knockout and as such RNA treated
hippocampal neurons
thus this study demonstrates the
importance of glutamate kinase receptor
subunit for the functioning of kcc2
co-transporter next let's look into a
paper published by Colin and colleagues
in nature neuroscience others try to
understand the role of que si si in
addiction why is this paper so important
drug addiction affects millions of
people worldwide but the mechanism is
not clearly understood yes I see role in
drug addiction is not known authors
demonstrate that AC is through heater to
unknown postsynaptic currents regulates
plasticity underlying addiction-related
behavior deletion of is I see one a by
knockout or si si 3 injection disrupted
acid your currents in the nucleus
accumbens region of the mice also as I
see one a knockout and selective partial
knockout of case I see one a in nucleus
accumbens mice exhibited a significantly
greater cocaine and morphine conditioned
place preference in addition yes I see
one year injection restored acid evoked
currents and produced conditioned place
preference to cocaine so as I see one a
induces as in your currents and required
for conditioned place preference what is
the mechanism of action as shown in this
figure yes icy currents contribute to
synaptic transmission yes I see one a
disruption increases dendritic spine
density and as shown here loss of case I
see one year increases inward
rectification of TMP a mediated epscs
which is normalized by reestablishing s
I see only express
thus si si plays a role in synaptic
transmission spine density and glutamate
receptor function next other show that
case I see one here disruption increases
am part to nmda ratio which is acutely
reversed by single dose of cocaine
overexpression of esic 1a in the rat
nucleus accumbens non significantly
enhanced acid you opt current but
significantly and as amiloride
sensitives synaptic currents and also
attenuated cocaine self-administration
so yes I see one a plays an important
role in drug addiction thank you for
watching science mission